Michael Beschloss author of the new book
the crisis years kennedy and khrushchev
1962-1963
let me read you just a fairly long
paragraph here page 702 of your book and
get your reaction to it but throughout
his term Kennedy rarely showed the
magnum entity it should have been
expected of a superior power instead he
aroused the Western world to an hour of
imminent danger that did not exist
provoke the adversary by exposing Soviet
nuclear weaknesses to the world and
unwittingly caused the Soviets to fear
that he was on the verge of exploiting
American nuclear strength to settle the
Cold War on American terms perhaps even
in a pre-emptive strike that was the
dark side of John Kennedy as a master of
foreign policy the argument I'm making
Brian is this in 1960 when John Kennedy
ran for president over and over again he
said the United States is an imminent
danger of falling into second place
behind the Russians now that the Cold
War is over and we have a lot more
information we know that the Soviet
Union in 1960 was actually a fourth-rate
economic power second-rate military
power had 118th the number of nuclear
weapons that we had so given all that
when kennedy came into power in 1961 he
couldn't very well just say sorry folks
what I said during the campaign is now
inoperative he had to act on the
assumption that not only was the Soviet
Union and equal but perhaps in danger of
becoming a superior and that was one of
the reasons why these three years 1960
to 1963 were so dangerous why did you
pick those three years why not 62 64 or
59 to 65 what was it well the argument I
make Brian is that 1960 to 1963 was a
period that was absolutely unique these
were the only three years in all of our
experience when Americans felt an
imminent danger of dying in a nuclear
war I would argue that that was not true
before 1960 and never happened again
after 1963 so
question I really wanted to ask was why
was it what was it about these three
years that made this period so dangerous
was it that the issues between the US
and the Soviet Union were greater or was
it something else and I found it was
something else how old were you in 1960
and where were you I was four years old
I was living in Illinois and I don't
have much memory of the 1960 campaign
but I do have a memory of later parts of
that period the Cuban Missile Crisis for
instance the fall of 62 we had neighbors
in Illinois this would have been about
40 miles south of Chicago who were
building a bomb shelter and we children
were told not to eat the snow because
the Russians had put radioactivity in it
so as a child I had a very intense
experience of the crisis years this was
not something that was abstract how did
you go about finding out what happened
in those years well the two things that
any historian tries to do is number one
turn up as new as much new information
as you can
and number two explain it and set it in
context new information in the last
couple of years thanks to Mikhail
Gorbachev you can go to the Soviet Union
and talk to Soviet officials quite
candidly about their past that wasn't
possible before Gorbachev so you have
for instance the testimony of someone
like Andrei Gromyko the Foreign Minister
why he lied to President Kennedy in
October of 1962 in saying there were no
missiles in Cuba and it's also had an
effect on the American side now that the
Cold War is over there are many people
in the CIA for instance Richard Helms
who I interviewed at great length who
will talk a lot more freely than when
these issues were more sensitive as far
as context now that were in a post Cold
War period we know how the Cold War
ended we've had 30 years since the
crisis years it's a lot easier to set
this period in perspective than when it
was really an early chapter of current
events you've been on the tour for how
long 10 said he is three weeks as you go
about talking about this what
want to know people are fascinated by
John Kennedy and this is something
that's very unlike most other presidents
usually when about thirty years passed a
president is sort of a figure in history
and not really a live presence John
Kennedy is someone who to this day stirs
up a great deal of controversy people
are very polarized people who love John
Kennedy don't see flaws in him and also
many people who hate him very few in the
middle and that's one reason why in this
book I've tried very much to walk down
the middle and show both his strengths
and also his weaknesses and present as
three-dimensional a picture of John
Kennedy as I possibly could have you
gotten any sense from the call-in shows
you've been on and other interviews
whether or not President Kennedy is up
or down in the eyes of most Americans I
think it's very polarized you know you
have segments that feel very intensely I
think you you saw a period just in terms
of the historiography of Kennedy after
his tragic death needless to say you you
saw many books written that were
extremely reverential many people like
McGeorge Bundy who did not wrote write a
book but wrote an article at the time
Bundy was Kennedy's national security
adviser he says that those who were
around Kennedy and who wrote books and
articles in the years after the
assassination were a little bit too
reverential then beginning in the middle
of the 1970s you had such things as the
Church Committee of the Senate that
investigated John Kennedy's possible
involvement in assassination plots and
also the possible security risks that
were caused by his private life that
caused the historiography the things
written on John Kennedy to take another
very sharp turn I don't know of any
President Brian where you've seen such
enormous zigzags and his reputation how
do you feel about I feel that I try to
walk really down the middle I think this
is someone who was a tremendous crisis
manager I think you have to remember
that given the fact that 61 and 62 and
63 were so dangerous especially over
Berlin and Cuba if it were not for John
Kennedy's very careful management of
those crises
you might have seen 200 million human
beings die I think he also was probably
the most or one of the most intelligent
presidents of this century at the same
time on the downside I don't rate him
very high on crisis avoidance as I show
in the book these crises I think did not
have to happen and simply because that
many people did not die does not mean
that we can entirely forgive either
Kennedy or Khrushchev for keeping the
world on the brink for three years one
of the things that struck me as I read
it where they were parallels between
President Kennedy and chairman
Khrushchev and the one simple parallel
that President Kennedy one of his chief
aides was his brother Bobby and one of
mr. Khrushchev chief advisors was his
son-in-law talk about the son-in-law or
frankly you haven't host what you
thought of mr. Khrushchev and also about
Bobby Kennedy those three men well there
was an enormous parallel between John
Kennedy and Nikita Khrushchev these were
two men who both distrusted the Foreign
Service bureaucracy and instead relied
on back channels one of the stories that
runs throughout the book is the
relationship that Khrushchev had named
with a man named Georg E bullsháá cough
bullsháá cough was a Soviet military
intelligence agent who was based in the
embassy in Washington he was under what
they call shallow cover as a press
attache he was a friend of Khrushchev
son man named Li al Xiao bei bolshakov
appeared in Robert Kennedy's office in
May of 1961 said essentially you don't
know me but I can get secret messages to
and from Khrushchev very quickly the
first message he sent in May of 1961 was
mr. Khrushchev wants a summit that led
to the summit between Kennedy and
Khrushchev in Vienna of June of 1961
so you see Brian a lot of the
relationship between Kennedy and
Khrushchev two men both distrustful in
Kennedy's case of his State Department
both very eager to work through other
channels
I mean his dinner at the second day this
is mr. as you may this is a Jubei who
came to see John Kennedy and
January of 1962 and that's what that as
bad as a picture of who's the woman
living that is his wife that is Nikita
Khrushchev daughter Radha and she is
wearing a mink coat for which she got a
lot of criticism at the time she was the
daughter of a leader who tried to live
rather modestly I'm sorry I interrupted
your train of thought
not a bit John Kennedy like Khrushchev
also wanted to work through a channel
that he could depend on and Robert
Kennedy beginning about the same time
spring of 1961 began to act as John
Kennedy's back channel to the CIA what
Richard Helms of the CIA calls John
Kennedy's wire brush man so much of the
history of this period you see Robert
Kennedy calling second and third level
officials in the CIA especially about
Cuba saying the president is very upset
he wants Castro out of Havana Castro was
still there what are you going to do
about it you mentioned early about new
information looking for new information
what do you consider to be the most
significant new information you've got
in this book I think the main new
information is what the Soviets were
doing through this period for example we
have seen the Cuban Missile Crisis and I
saw it at the time as a child as sort of
a passion play that Nikita Khrushchev
for sinister reasons that we couldn't
understand out of the blue move missiles
into Cuba John Kennedy demanded that he
takes them out the missiles went out and
that was the end of it what I found from
my soviet interviews was that the
reality was a little bit more complex
the people who were around Khrushchev
say that in early 1962 Khrushchev was
very worried about something named
Operation Mongoose this was 33 different
covert operations waged by the CIA
against Cuba sabotage poisoning of sugar
exports shooting from motor boats and
also efforts to assassinate Fidel Castro
Castro and Khrushchev thought that
operation Mongoose was the forerunner to
an American invasion of Cuba with full
US military force probably in the fall
of 1962 it turns out that Castro and
Khrushchev
put their heads together asking the
question what can we possibly do that
will port this American invasion of Cuba
the answer that they came up with was
put in nuclear missiles make sure hear
of mr. Khrushchev and Dean Rusk you
paint a picture of Dean Rusk in this
book that I'll let you describe Dean
Rusk was not a very happy Secretary of
State during the crisis years this is
someone who did not know John Kennedy
really before he was appointed in
December of 1960 John Kennedy wanted to
act very much as his own Secretary of
State and what you see through this
period and we've seen it certainly in
other administrations is John Kennedy
and others in the White House making an
effort to circumvent Rusk use other
channels such as Robert Kennedy McGeorge
Bundy the National Security Advisor
and other people who were more Kennedy
men what really happened particularly to
Rusk was that he fell afoul of Robert
Kennedy Robert Kennedy thought that Rusk
was more loyal to the State Department
than to John Kennedy there was very
fierce tension between Robert Kennedy
and Dean Rusk throughout these years a
line in your epilogue returning from a
Saigon trip in March and this was in
1964 I believe McNamara recommended new
assistance to South Vietnam that brought
up the name of Robert McNamara what do
you think of him and what role did he
play in the Vietnam War Robert Kennedy
or I should say Robert McNamara the
Secretary of Defense absolutely
captivated Kennedy Kennedy was very
taken by him and in fact one of the
things I show in the book is that John
Kennedy very seriously considered naming
Robert McNamara as his successor as
president assuming that he's who served
two terms and was able to name his
successor at the Democratic convention
of 1968 McNamara was a businessman very
hard to get those four Democratic
administrations in those days was
extremely articulate very sharp
dominated almost any meeting he entered
Kennedy's people were a little bit
worried about Mack
they felt that sometimes he was so
forceful so persuasive that he was able
to get John Kennedy to do things that he
shouldn't have on the question of
Vietnam what this particularly raises as
you suggest is the question of what John
Kennedy might have done had he lived and
had to make the same decision on Vietnam
that Lyndon Johnson did many have said
that John Kennedy said in 1963 privately
I want to get reelected first then when
I come back to power I'll get our troops
out of Vietnam I tend to find that not
very persuasive for two reasons number
one is Kennedy would have been advised
by exactly the same people especially
Robert McNamara who advised Lyndon
Johnson in 1965 to plunge deeply into
Vietnam and the other reason Bryan is
that I think it takes some cynicism to
assume that John Kennedy would have kept
thousands of Americans in South Vietnam
in harm's way getting killed only to
pull them out in 1965 after allowing
them to be killed for essentially
domestic reasons the winning of the 1964
election was it Robert McNamara that
asked President Kennedy or somebody did
you really write profiles and courage
before he took the job he did he met
with John Kennedy whom he did not know
in Georgetown at John Kennedy's house in
1960 and McNamara I think a because he's
a forceful person and be because perhaps
he knew that Kennedy would be impressed
said before I agree to be your Secretary
of Defense I want two things number one
I'd like to know if you really wrote
profiles encourage Kennedy said that he
did and number two I'd like written
assurance that you're going to give me
full independence and Secretary of
Defense that I can name my own people
Kennedy gave him that you say you grew
up in Illinois where grew up born in
Chicago
lived in Chicago for my first five years
and then lived in a town called floss
more which is at the south end of Cook
County in fact the county of a John
Kennedy credited with giving him the
1960 election
your parents do my father is a
businessman my mother was a homemaker I
guess one would say not terribly
politically involved although my father
was the president of the school board in
town and where did you go to school
meaning in college I went to college in
Massachusetts at Williams College and
went to graduate school at Harvard what
got you interested in history was
interested in history from the time I
was a small boy and in fact the first
serious book of all things I ever read
was arthur schlesinger 'he's a thousand
days at the age of ten I never thought
it would be useful later on to having a
having read it but I think one thing
Brian and you're from the Midwest too
unlike people who live in the East I
think people who grew up in the Midwest
to some extent have the sense that
historical events are somewhat detached
from them I for instance had never met
someone who had written a book until I
was probably fifteen years old had not
met people who were in political life
until I was about that age that is an
experience I think someone who lives in
the East would be less likely to have so
I think reading about these events made
me very interested in how they take
place and want to write about them later
on did you what got you interested in a
thousand days and Arthur Schlessinger
why did you read that book yeah I do I
was very interested in John Kennedy and
as a matter of fact he was one of my
childhood heroes when he died I wrote a
letter to President Johnson asking him
to hire a large carving firm to carve
President Kennedy's head and Mount
Rushmore and I got a reply from
Johnson's secretary saying thank you for
the advice and I couldn't remember
taking the reply to my friends at the
ice-skating rink in town they all
thought it was a forgery
years later when I was doing work in the
Johnson library I said I'm sure you
won't have this but maybe you keep some
children's letters and at about five
minutes they were able to pull it out so
I have a Xerox of the original letter
your first book Kennedy and Roosevelt
the uneasy alliance 1980 it was about
what that was on the relationship
between John Kennedy's father Joseph
Kennedy senior and Franklin Roosevelt
which was actually my original
undergraduate honors thesis at Williams
College
in Massachusetts was interested in those
two characters because I was very
interested in political leadership
Joseph Kennedy and Franklin Roosevelt
were people who were about the same age
and in the 1920s it had business careers
during that period in American business
that was not terribly unlike the 1950s
in the 1980s periods in which business
was very dominant in our culture and
then were in politics of course in the
30s and 40s
Kennedy was wonderful in business made a
great fortune Roosevelt went through a
number of schemes to make money and
almost always lost money in every one
yet of course when Roosevelt went back
into politics in the 1930s was one of
our greatest presidents and had this
very strange relationship with Joseph
Kennedy that culminated in Joseph
Kennedy's ambassadorship in the early
period of World War two your second book
Mayday
Eisenhower Khrushchev and u2 and the u2
affair 1986 why'd you do that one that
was a book that was really dealing with
the late years of the Eisenhower period
and as a diplomatic historian you really
want to work with fresh material that
was a book that was written in the early
1980s and the most recent documents that
were being unsealed under the Freedom of
Information Act were documents from the
late Eisenhower period so that was a
situation in which I was able to take
fresh material and interpret it for
perhaps the first time what do you do
besides write books I write books about
95 percent of the time I've been a
treasurer of a small foundation the
pen/faulkner foundation here in
Washington and also the director of a
program funded by the Annenberg
foundation on the impact of television
on American foreign policy when did you
start writing or gathering information
for this current book started the crisis
years in 1985 and that was a time when
you simply assumed that you were not
able to get Soviet sources when I was
writing Mayday I would write to various
so it Soviet figure is quite dutifully
and I would get letters back saying
mrs. Khrushchev has been consulted and
does not wish to be interviewed at this
time well that was not unusual because
mrs. Khrushchev never wished to be
interviewed she wasn't allowed to be and
I sometimes joke that things have
changed so much that if mrs. Khrushchev
were still alive I would get a letter
back from her lecture agent saying that
her hotel suite had to be equipped with
guava juice and that she would demand a
very high price this book has 816 pages
I Canada but I can't find the page where
the number of pages of notes and indexes
and all that come up to about a hundred
pages when do you decide how big of
books going to be in this book sells for
$29.95 I assume there's a lot you left
out there is I think the the largest
responsibility I had on this book Bryan
was to write a book that really could
accommodate the new information I think
if there hadn't been that new
information I've referred to from the
Soviet Union from the CIA on this side
and from a lot of other American German
and Soviet figures who were willing to
speak quite candidly these days it would
have been a much shorter book since I
was turning up a lot of new information
that was not yet in the public domain I
wanted to write a book that was as
consistently surprising and fresh as
possible and it really took 800 pages to
do it the most valuable source the most
valuable source I think was as a body
these interviews in the Soviet Union
because this really increased entirely
by a hundred percent the amount of
information we had on the Soviet side
you could find out for instance what
Khrushchev was saying to his son during
the months before the Cuban Missile
Crisis what he and the East Germans were
telling each other during the weeks
leading up to the Berlin wall how he
greeted the news of John Kennedy's Bad
Pigs invasion it turned out that it
happened on Khrushchev's birthday he was
sitting in his indoor/outdoor pool on
his estate in the Black Sea and he said
this is a very surprising birthday
present I don't want you to give way in
your secret techniques but when you want
to go look for information in the Soviet
how do you do it well you do it in a
number of ways one is you simply write
to people and interview them for
instance I talked to Sarah gay
Khrushchev who was nikita khrushchev son
and who came to the United States for
the first time in 1989 the first time
then since the famous trip he took with
his father in 1959 when they toured this
country and went to Hollywood and
finally Nikita Khrushchev met with Eisen
Howard can't David the other source it's
very important is that these people now
are very eager to write memoirs in
magazines newspapers and also in book
form Sarah gave Khrushchev for instance
published a volume of memoirs last year
Alexei azu Bey the son-in-law of
Christian has been serially publishing
his memoirs in his vest gia which in the
early 1960 who was the paper of which he
was editor do you speak Russian I don't
and as a matter of fact before a couple
of years ago it probably wouldn't have
hurt me because you were dealing mainly
with reading between the lines of Pravda
and that you could get translated as it
turns out it hasn't hurt me that much
with this because most of the people I
would have wanted to interview have a
pretty good command of English but I
think any historian who wants to write
American Soviet history in the future I
think we'll have to have a very good
command of Russian what is Sergei
Khrushchev like and how old is in orders
he lived he is in his late 50s he is
living in Moscow he looks actually not
unlike his father although he's a little
bit thinner and he had a very poignant
experience
this is someone who during his father's
reign until 1964 was treated something
like a crown prince lived in a way that
was very lavish although he's a somewhat
modest person was treated extremely well
one of the stories that I have in the
book is the story of the fact that in
the fall of 1964 he was given
information that there was a coup d'etat
plot against Nikita Khrushchev and that
chairman Khrushchev had better watch out
that puts Sergei into a little bit of a
dilemma because he and his father had an
arrangement they would never talk about
business he would not presume to
advised his father about matters of
state
finally he swallowed his doubts told
Khrushchev that there was this plot
afoot this was September of 1964
Khrushchev checked into it and said this
is absurd Sergei the people that you're
talking about all hate each other
they're not going to deal with each
other in a coup d'etat I'm not going to
take it seriously
a month later those people actually did
combine they threw Khrushchev out of
power
this is who you dedicate the book to in
the front who is this and how do you
pronounce it it's off sunny Masha a he
she is a distinguished Iranian economist
at the World Bank and a very close
friend of mine and put up with me during
the years of writing this book how do
you write where do you write I mean
what's the system that you use because
one of the things that I noticed in
reading this is that it this is probably
not a fair comparison but in reading the
commander's by Bob Woodward you saw the
quote marks and you know and in order to
find out where these quote marks come
from you got to go all the way to the
back here and look in the notes tell us
about that technique how does that story
in do this well I think first of all
Brian a book a work of history and Bob
Woodward's book would be contemporary
journalism but a book of history thirty
years later has to really be able to
stand up to the test of sources I think
if you don't have a very clear idea as a
reader where the material book in the
book comes from you don't know whether
to take it seriously or not so every
sentence in the book is documented I say
where it comes from usually from
documents I try not to rely to rely on
interviews I much prefer to rely on for
instance the contemporary record of the
Kennedy and Khrushchev summit the
transcript that was made that is
something that was sealed for all these
years until about seven months ago it
was unsealed just in time to put into
this book so I think what you try to do
or at least what I try to do is take as
much new material as you possibly can
and in my case I'm a narrative historian
I tell this in terms of a story to some
extent using fictional techniques
although every syllable in the book is
fact I think that you can take great
personalities
the cast of characters in this book
people like Robert Kennedy and Lyndon
Johnson and Andrei Gromyko and others
and give it almost the texture of a
story with a great theme in this case
the three years during which the world
was almost incinerated yet at the same
time caused this all to remain within
the constraints of very documental fact
page 6:15 by pursuing women whose full
backgrounds he evidently could not know
Kennedy caused his presidency to be a
potential hostage to any resourceful
group in American society that might
have wished to bring him down
the Teamsters the Mafia the radical
right and every hostile intelligence
service in the world what is that all
about well any historian has to deal
with the question of John Kennedy's
private life as an historian I'm not
particularly fascinated by what he did
in his bedroom but as someone who's
writing about his diplomacy I have to
deal with the question of whether this
ever threatened to affect him as a world
leader and the answer I think has to be
yes every piece of information we have
suggests that the women that John
Kennedy was involved with were not
subjected to some kind of a background
investigation what that meant was that
he was very vulnerable to getting
involved with women who might have been
involved with some kind of an
organization that might wish to
blackmail him for its own purposes we
know from the Senate investigation of
the mid-1970s for instance that John
Kennedy was involved with a woman named
Judith Exner who was at the same time
involved with Sam Giancana who was an
underworld organized crime leader in
Chicago at the same time during this
period we know that Soviet intelligence
was trying very hard to sexually
compromise Western leaders we know as a
fact for instance that they succeeded
during this period with the Soviet
ambassador from France or I should say
the French ambassador to Moscow also the
British defense minister in 1963 John
Profumo who shared a woman
Christine Keeler with a member of the
Soviet embassy he had to resign so the
point I would make here Bryant is that
this was not just a free-floating
anxiety this is something that could
have happened and I think as a
diplomatic historian John Kennedy should
have been more careful me pursue this a
little more because you suggest that at
anytime any of these people could have
blackmailed him why didn't they that's
one of the great $64,000 questions they
didn't I think perhaps because there
wasn't the motive I mean it's hard to
get into the head of someone like
Giancana or the Soviet intelligence
service but I think for a diplomatic
historian all you have to do was
establish the risk as long as that risk
remained then really the country was at
risk because I would argue that if John
Kennedy for instance had been revealed
to have been involved with someone who
was linked to Soviet intelligence and
this may have been true not only would
he probably have had to resign amid a
sex and security scandal very much like
the Christine Keeler scandal in Great
Britain in 1963 but it would have had a
very poisonous effect on the politics of
this country other leaders would have
been suspect people would have said did
John Kennedy for instance pull his
punches at the Bay of Pigs because he
was under some kind of compromised by
Soviet intelligence it would have been a
very ugly atmosphere did you discover
any new information related to the judas
campbell affair that he had in sam
giancana i cover it and the tricky part
of this here is that Judith Campbell at
the time that she was involved with
Kennedy was involved with Giancana who
had been hired by the CIA to try to
murder Fidel Castro the question is
whether there was a link between Kennedy
and Giancana on the murder of Castro
I've not found evidence of this and I've
tried to be as absolutely careful as I
could in separating the wheat from the
chaff what we could be sure of what we
could not be sure oh all right let me
see if I can understand this Sam
Giancana had been he was the leader of
the Mafia in Chicago in Chicago had been
hired by the CIA to take out Fidel
Castro that is a story that we do
know for certain in 1960 he was
approached by officials of the CIA who
essentially said we know that you have
associates in Cuba because the Mafia was
very involved in Cuba before Castro it
was estimated that the Mafia was taking
in a billion dollars a year from their
concessions in Havana and elsewhere on
the island
the Mafia said we would like you to use
your acquaintances to kill Castro this
plot went on through 1961 and 1962
I interviewed Richard Helms who was in
charge of it for the CIA he says that by
the end of 1962 he did not have very
much more hope that the Mafia was able
to kill Castro he felt that if they
hadn't succeeded by then they never
would and in fact some of the teams that
were sent in he felt were probably cast
captured by the Castro regime he felt
that it was worthwhile pursuing the plot
however because he wanted to see what
kind of assets the mob might have in
Cuba that might be useful to the CIA
all right Sam Giancana and Judy Campbell
soon to become Exner were lovers at the
same time that the President Kennedy and
Judy Campbell were together by the
evidence that came up during the Senate
investigations of the mid nineteen
seventy-one I'm getting at though the
behind all this was at the time was
Bobby Kennedy in the Justice Department
pursuing the mob he was in fact he
pursued the mob much more energetically
than any previous Attorney General and
so what this raises of course is whether
the mob expected to get better treatment
from the Kennedy administration because
they felt themselves to be doing these
favors for the CIA which was under
President Kennedy and whether they were
outraged at the fact that many mafia
leaders were being very energetically
sent to jail by Robert Kennedy another
liaison you write about here is Ellen
finn'll how do you pronounce that roma
roma ch the reason I bring that one up
is she was a 27 year old wife of a West
German airman attached to the West
German military mission in Washington
but later on you get into the fact that
senators Mansfield and Dirksen got into
this act tell us that story well this
comes from FBI files that have been
opened only in the last several years
and I might parenthetically say that FBI
files turn out to be a very interesting
source for the historian you have to be
very careful because in some cases FBI
files will have reports that are from
unreliable sources and you've got to
take those with a grain of salt in other
cases you have a situation where there
are wire taps on telephones and you get
an exact account of a conversation
none of us historians would ever
expected that J Edgar Hoover the
director of the FBI would turn out to be
so useful to us of course that was not
his purpose in the summer of 1963 Hoover
went to Robert Kennedy and said we have
information that not only your brother
the president but others in Washington
have been involved with the woman whom
we suspect as a Soviet intelligence
agent someone who was linked to East
German intelligence Robert Kennedy took
it seriously enough that he acted very
quickly to control the damage he spoke
with the two leaders of the Senate
Dirksen and Mansfield the Republican and
Democrat asked them to keep to
themselves whatever knowledge they had
of this he also had the woman expelled
from this country within a week flown to
West Germany she was put in a house that
was surrounded by guards to keep people
away and so whatever scandal might have
occurred did not occur this was a crisis
that was basically kept under control
but the historian once again has to say
that that very well could have become
public it very nearly did had it done so
you could very well have had a Red Scare
in this country that would have dwarfed
the Joseph McCarthy period were you also
saying here that J Edgar Hoover had an
enormous amount of power because he had
this information that he could use
against the president at any time
absolutely and we know from history that
J Edgar Hoover
is not love to use- Faiz files against
presidents and Senators and others for
his own purposes one more once before a
romance had threatened Kennedy's career
it was in early 1942 as an naval
intelligence officer that he was
involved with Inga Arvid
Fay housed a married woman and a reputed
recent mistress of Alex Verner gren a
Swede blacklisted by the State
Department for his close association
with Hermann Goering what's that about
well the reason why I found John
Kennedy's failure to be a little bit
more careful about women he saw while
President was because once before during
World War two he had come very near to
having his career ended by a liaison
with someone who is under suspicion of
being an agent this is a woman who at
the time was under suspicion by the FBI
and Franklin Roosevelt's attorney
general of being a Nazi agent in
Washington FBI files recently unsealed
which I use in the book show that she
went around Washington declaiming what
she referred to as the damn dirty Jews
that she had been involved with Hitler
Circle in the mid 1930s John Kennedy at
the time was a lieutenant in Naval
Intelligence
this was after Pearl Harbor it's hard to
say that a 25 year old man did not know
what it meant to be in intelligence and
have an affair with a woman who was
suspected of being a Nazi spy the FBI
files demonstrate that he was aware of
this he wrote letters which appear in
the files referring to her as a spy and
a sort of joking fashion if all this
were known during or before the kennedy
election years would it have damaged him
back then and would you think he would
have still been elected president I
think it would be very unlikely that
John Kennedy would have become president
in 1960 had this information become
known and what is the reaction on the
part of the public since and some of
this is new information as I understand
in your book yes part of its present
Bryant for instance when the book came
out there were two Associated Press
stories about the book one was on this
material the other was on my new
findings on the bay of pigs the Berlin
Wall on the Cuban Missile Crisis the
first article was picked up by about
1,200 newspapers the second article by a
number that was radically less than that
I think the more serious reaction is
that it has to come into our assessment
of John Kennedy this is someone who as
I've said has enormous has had enormous
strengths did a great deal for this
country during these years yet at the
same time there was a side of him that
caused him to do things that really he
shouldn't have and could have threatened
the political system these are odds and
ends things I wanted to ask you about is
when I read the book Nikita Khrushchev
spent 25 days in this country at one
point yes that was during the campaign
of 1960 Nikita Khrushchev felt that he
felt that he could have some influence
over who became president in 1960 he
took a boat over to New York and spent
that many days in New York II in this
country and at the UN that was when he
had the famous incident when he beat his
shoe on the table as a matter of fact
one of the things I found out from
Soviet sources this has always been
taken as an example of what a buffoon
and crude person Khrushchev was it turns
out that was a planned gesture
Khrushchev and the UN was trying to
create a sense of solidarity with many
third world nations the proletariat of
these nations he felt that a gesture
like this that was somewhat peasant like
would win him a few friends and as it
turns out much of the 1960 campaign was
fought over the issue as Kennedy and
Nixon said of who could stand up to
Khrushchev that was very unlike 1952 you
did not have Eisenhower and Adlai
Stevenson competing on the basis of who
could stand up to Stalin you write a lot
or you reference a lot about John
Kennedy's back pain what kind of effect
that had moaning in May of 1961 John
Kennedy re-injured his bad back in a
tree-planting ceremony in Canada it put
him in a very difficult situation
because
he was planning to meet Nikita
Khrushchev at a summit in Vienna at the
beginning of June
he said privately as I have in the book
I don't want to go see Khrushchev is a
[ __ ] on crutches he had to act fast
as it turns out in order to fix his back
trouble he resorted to a doctor in New
York called max Jacobson who we now look
on as a not very serious or responsible
doctor someone who experimented with on
feta means put a lot of things in his
hypodermic needles that most doctors
would not consider to be a very good
thing as it turns out Kennedy had this
doctor flown to Vienna he injected
Kennedy on some occasions during the
intermissions between his meetings with
Khrushchev I was interested as an
historian whether this affected
Kennedy's performance and pediments can
make you go up and down can make you
garrulous or sometimes make you very low
from the transcripts of the Vienna
meeting as there is no sense that
Kennedy was affected by these
amphetamines this was a gamble that he
took at one was President Kennedy
fatalistic he was fatalistic in certain
ways in managing for instance the Berlin
crisis and the Cuban Missile Crisis you
will see no president who was more
responsible Cuban Missile Crisis for
instance we know because he made secret
tapes of the meetings in the Cabinet
Room and you could listen to them as I
did and I put a lot of the dialogue in
this book this is someone who asked
excellent questions was very much
hands-on there was no question who was
in charge but John Kennedy was
fatalistic in two ways as I write in the
book one was with women as I say he took
chances that could have had national
security implications chances I think he
shouldn't have taken another way he was
fatalistic was he was very interested in
death
George Smathers the senator from Florida
and a great friend of Kennedy told me in
an interview that 20 times or more John
Kennedy would say to him what do you
think is the best way to die is it
better to get shot is it better to drown
is it better to die slowly so that you
could have some time to think
about it I think both of these forms of
fatalism had to do with the fact that in
John Kennedy's early life he was under
the impression that he would die at an
early age from Addison's disease this is
something that he suffered from until
about 1950 it was almost always fatal
and that was a time when he formed
essentially this personal policy of
living for the moment because tomorrow
you die you talk about two news men in
here that were deeply involved in
American is Minh in liaison one of them
John Scally
with ABC News and was our UN Ambassador
the story's fairly well known although
you suggest that you found out that
maybe that story wasn't really well he
didn't play as bigger roles we think he
played yes I think John Sculley is
absolutely right in what he said all
these years which is that during the
Cuban Missile Crisis he met with a
Soviet intelligence official named
Alexander foe mean those meetings I am
certain took place at the Occidental
restaurant at the Occidental restaurant
the predecessor of the Occidental
restaurant that is now here in
Washington but at the same time what
scollay could not know was who
authorized for me to have these meetings
of anyone and what importance that had
in Moscow what we now know from Soviet
sources as I write in the book is that
far from being authorized by Khrushchev
which is the impression that
skali had a full mean and also the
Americans who knew about these meetings
foe main was freelancing people in the
Soviet embassy during the Cuban Missile
Crisis in Washington had been told
basically to try it to get as much
information as you possibly can
and four main was an example of this and
it turns out that the information he
sent back to Moscow arrived at times
that would not have influenced important
decisions so it turns out to be an
incident interesting vignette but I
think not one that really changed the
course of history
Frank Holman New York Daily News who was
he and why do you key why'd you write so
much about it Frank Holman is still
living as far as I know he was a White
House correspondent for the New York
Daily News and
early 60s he was approached by the
gentleman I referred to earlier gay orgy
[ __ ] off this soviet intelligence
agent in washington whom he knew he was
on the board of the National Press Club
knew [ __ ] off through the Press Club
bolshakov came to Holman and said I want
to meet with Robert Kennedy I know that
you know him and you've covered him
perhaps you could introduce me and it
was Holman who made the introduction
that led to the first meeting between
Robert Kennedy and bolshakov in May of
1961 were you surprised at how active a
role that a news person would have
played in the process yes and to use
news people as intermediaries Holman and
Scalli and others I think shows really
how different the crisis years were from
our own time nowadays President Bush can
pick up a telephone and call mr.
Gorbachev in the early 60s Kennedy and
Khrushchev were reduced to sending
secret messages through news men through
intelligence agents in fact bolshakov
would sometimes meet members of the
kennedy administration on street corners
or in saloons he would pass them a
newspaper inside the newspaper was a
secret private message from Khrushchev
to Kennedy this was a very dicey way to
conduct international relations now
their odds and ends
continuing somewhere I read and had
quote marks around it that Adlai
Stevenson couldn't control the smile on
his face at the death the notice of the
death of John Kennedy that's poignant
the night of the death of John Kennedy
Arthur Schlesinger says he saw Stevenson
at the White House and he said Stevenson
had a smile on his face Schlesinger who
had worked for Stevenson in his
campaigns in the 1950s said I never felt
the same way about Stevenson after that
the relationship between John Kennedy
and Adlai Stevenson is something I go
into a great deal in this book Stevenson
of course had been the nominee of the
Democratic Party in the 50s was still in
1961 when John Kennedy became president
probably the most popular Democrat in
the country more popular among Democrats
than Kennedy was Kennedy was very eager
to cut Stevenson down
sighs he didn't want him as a rival he
also knew that Stephens who could be
very dangerous if Stevenson whom he had
appointed ambassador to the United
Nations should ever decide to resign in
protest over a Kennedy policy I think
another part of this was that Kennedy
felt very emotionally about Stevenson
Kennedy was not someone who was without
a streak of cruelty and he did a number
of things to make Stevenson feel small
and essentially as I I say cut him down
to size
what did you think of Governor Stevenson
as an Illinois and I would be a great
Stephenson fan and Stevenson's name is
almost wholly in Illinois I would say
that his years in the Kennedy
administration were very poignant very
sad a time in which someone who is used
to being the center of attention with a
great deal of influence was a member of
administration that did not like him did
not consult him played cruel tricks on
him who are some of the people that you
got to know in your research for this
book that were around the Kennedy
administration that surprised you as to
how interesting they were some people we
haven't talked about one example was
McGeorge Bundy who was Kennedy's
national security adviser and is now a
writer and scholar on the history of
nuclear weapons he is someone who has a
wonderful sense of humor very smart a
very useful instrument of Kennedy's
diplomacy another one that I've
interviewed is Richard Helms who as I've
suggested earlier now that the Cold War
is over will speak very freely about
many subjects that would have been very
sensitive during this period not least
his involvement in the assassination
attempts against Castro and that raises
sort of a very sensitive and interesting
problem Brian and that is that for all
these years there's been an effort by
people to establish whether or not John
Kennedy knew of and approved of the
assassination attempts by the CIA
against Castro Helms has always been in
a very difficult position because he
prides himself on on being the man who
kept the secrets as a biography of him
was once entitled someone who has not
betrayed the faith that he feel
that he had as a CIA official at the
same time many people around John
Kennedy have made the argument Kennedy
would never have approved of these
militant of these murder attempts
against Castro the CIA was going off on
its own on a rogue operation Helms will
not say that Kennedy approved them yet
at the same time I would say that he is
at least to some extent justifiably
irritated with the fact that the Kennedy
people blame him for something that he
feels John Kennedy authorized one thing
I found in my interviews George Smathers
told me that a month before the Bay of
Pigs invasion in the spring of 61
Kennedy told him there is an effort to
murder Castro that I know about this is
to take place just before a thousand
Cuban exile strained by the CIA hit the
beaches of Cuba trying to overthrow a
Cuban government
if Castro is killed just before those
men hit the beaches there will be chaos
and pandemonium they will have a good
chance of succeeding that to some extent
answers the question of why Kennedy
authorized this very small ragtag group
of invaders that otherwise would seem to
have been impossible to succeed in
invading Cuba how close did we come to
in clear war we came very close
throughout the whole period especially
in 1961 over Berlin Nikita Khrushchev
threatened a number of times to take
over Berlin we the United States and the
West had promised that we would go to
the point of nuclear war to resist that
we were very close then second time was
during the Cuban Missile Crisis October
of 62 the Joint Chiefs of Staff had
resolved if an American plane were
downed in Cuba during that crisis we
would automatically bomb the Soviet
missile sites it took John Kennedy to
stand up against the Joint Chiefs and
say no had he not stood up those sites
would have been bombed Russians would
have been killed
Nikita Khrushchev would have been under
enormous pressure to retaliate against
the United States
another interesting scene was
when mr. Khrushchev I know I'm jumping
all over the place here but there's so
much it's a big book when mr. Khrushchev
got bounced from being the chairman of
the party in the Soviet Union can you
build that little scenario around and
how did he you touched on what his son
had told him that there was a threat
against him but what actually happened
and how did he find out that his days
were over well I think it starts really
with a whole history of his last year
which began with John Kennedy's
assassination when Kennedy was killed in
Dallas the CIA tried to locate
Khrushchev they couldn't find him there
was some worry that Khrushchev was in a
bomb shelter somewhere outside Moscow
bracing for American retaliation for
Soviet involvement in Kennedy's murder
and Khrushchev in fact rushed the next
day the day after the assassination to
the US ambassador in Moscow and said you
must believe me I was not behind this
Kennedy's death removed the argument
that Khrushchev had made with his own
people that you must keep me in power
I'm indispensable because I have this
wonderful relationship with the American
president once John Kennedy died he
could no longer say that and there was a
coup d'etat in 1964 led by Leonid
Brezhnev and this we only now know from
Soviet sources not only did Brezhnev
wanna take Khrushchev out of power and
replace him he also wanted to kill him
he went to the director of the KGB
during that period and said Khrushchev
is scheduled to fly from Cairo to Moscow
why don't you put a bomb aboard the
plane then Brezhnev thought better of
the idea not because he felt any more
sentimental about Khrushchev but because
Andrei Gromyko the Foreign Minister was
on that plane
Brezhnev figured that he would need
Gromyko when he came to power the result
was that in October of 1964 Brezhnev and
other people who Khrushchev thought to
be his closest allies joined together
Khrushchev flew from the Black Sea to
Moscow appeared at a meeting in the
Kremlin they told him he was
he begged to be appointed at least
Minister of Agriculture he did not want
to give up power
they told him essentially forget it and
that was the end of Khrushchev he lived
until 1971 in a small house he was given
outside Moscow he was massively
depressed this was a man who was very
used to power to isolate him for seven
years was almost the worst thing you
could do the picture that you paint
though is mr. Khrushchev being at his
dacha or wherever he was and getting a
phone call from the Politburo that's
right and saying you come to you come to
Moscow he was told to come to Moscow and
Khrushchev and his normally high-handed
way said you know can't you deal with
this when I get back to Moscow next
month nothing should be so important
that I have to interrupt my vacation
they told him that he'd better come now
he was flown to Moscow he got off the
plane rather than the usual welcoming
delegation the only one who was there
was the chairman of the KGB and he had
Chris job driven to this meeting in
Moscow question today with mr. Gorbachev
could that same thing happen
no this coup d'etat depended on the fact
that leaders of the Soviet Union in the
early 1960s were selected by a very
small group if that small group turned
against you you were out a small group
of the same kind tried to throw
Khrushchev out once before in 1957 and
almost succeeded these curves were not
very unusual in those days nowadays as
the Soviet Union becomes more
pluralistic and more people have a say
in who becomes not only the leader of
the Soviet Union but leaders of the
Republic's it's going to be a lot harder
for a group of six men to come together
and simply say you are no longer
employed in the Kremlin is there any new
information to still find out about
Nikita Khrushchev there is it is said
that Khrushchev papers were destroyed
just after Khrushchev was taken out of
power by the order of Leonid Brezhnev
Brezhnev knew that Khrushchev was still
very popular among the Soviet people he
wanted to wipe out any trace of
Khrushchev and therefore not only had
apparently his papers destroyed but also
had the Soviet press and Soviet
publishing and other officials refused
ever to mention the name in Christian
the name Khrushchev in public and
therefore between 1964 and recent years
you've had a whole generation of Soviet
citizens growing up who have never heard
Chris John's name mentioned his Sergei
Khrushchev the son book credible yes it
was written about two years ago and it
was vetted translated and edited by an
eminent scholar American scholar of
Soviet affairs our that Khrushchev
memoirs credible the Khrushchev memoir
is there was some talk when they were
published this was Khrushchev talking
into a tape recorder the tapes were
smuggled to the west and published in
1970 1974 there was some talk at the
time there was there was rarely any
doubt that this was actually Chris Jost
voice there was some talk of the time
that as the price of getting the memoirs
out he was forced to put in some
disinformation that with getting the
memoirs out he was forced to put in some
disinformation that would throw off
Western intelligence my take on them now
is that he told the truth as he knew it
but Chris Geoff's view in many cases was
very distorted he also didn't have
access to his own records your next book
my next book is on Bush and Gorbachev
which I am writing in collaboration with
a journalist strobe Talbott of Time
magazine we are aspiring to write an
account of how this relationship has
developed between these two leaders
between 1989 and 1992 based on
interviews with Soviets and Americans
were expecting it to come out in the
fall of 1992 analyzed question are you
happy with the way this books played out
and the way it's being bought and read I
have this is a book that in many ways
very much disagrees with much of what
has been written about the history of
the crisis years over the last thirty
years many of the people who have
Judit have been people whose work I have
to some extent revised based on both new
information and also additional
perspective and they've treated it
respectfully and for that I'm grateful
Michael Beschloss author of the crisis
years kennedy and khrushchev 1962-1963
thank you for joining us thank you Brian